yep i am catching some pokemons
yeah you know pokemon go is crazy
millions of people play this game and it
scales like that
did you know that it was built on google
cloud
well let's talk to technical manager at
niantic labs to take a behind-the-scenes
look at pokemon go's architecture and
how it scales for a large number of
players hi james welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me i'm excited
to be here well for those who may not be
familiar with pokemon go let's quickly
go over what it is so pokemon go is not
your typical mobile game it's a game
that involves
walking around catching these little
creatures around you called pokemon that
are appearing
in the real world it encouraged you to
go outside explore and discover things
using augmented reality a big part of
that which wasn't included in the game
when it first came out was this big
community aspect of it
players would go out and meet with other
players in real life
do it play play together battle in gyms
and even like point it out when there
was this rare powerful pokemon that
would appear somewhere in your in your
uh map uh everyone sees the same pokemon
so you even see this in like youtube
clips out there but uh sometimes
somebody would just yell out hey there's
a charizard here and you would see
crowds of pokemon running towards that
direction
so nowadays we we really like this part
of the game so we we made it a major
part by hosting regular live events such
as community days raid hours team go
rocket takeovers all culminates in this
big summer event that we call go fest so
it's clear that lots of people are
playing at any given time especially
during go fest how does pokemon go back
and actually scale to handle these peaks
and traffic so we use google cloud
we have lots of services that that need
scaling such as the
google kubernetes engine and spanner our
front end service is hosted on gke and
it's pretty easy to scale the notes
there
google cloud provides us with all the
tools we need to manage the kubernetes
cluster the the cloud console is just
really easy to use and comes with
detailed monitoring graphs tools logging
all included and it's just a few clicks
away in the past
go fest we had google engineers
virtually sitting with us side by side
and ready to tackle any issues that
could come from from the event
it was like having an extra support team
working directly for us
to give an idea of scale
we have about 5 000 spanner nodes
handling the traffic and thousands of
kubernetes nodes running just for the
pokemon go service we also have the
various
micro services that host
um
other
parts of the game that help augment the
game experience
all these work together to support
millions of players playing the game all
across the world at any given moment
and if you compare ourselves to like
maybe world of warcraft you'll see that
other massively multiplayer online games
they they split players into multiple
realms but for us all of our players
they they reside in a single realm it
was important for us that the players
can always interact with each other and
share the same game experience no matter
where or when they're playing yeah it's
like making sure it's one same world and
one same similar view that that you're
sharing with all the players which is
what makes the game so amazing
you mentioned spanner and gke was it
always banner and gke or did you decide
to make that architectural decision as
the game got popular so we actually
started off with google data store it
was an easy way for us to just get
started
without having to worry about another
piece of infrastructure that we needed
to manage and scale and deal with all
those things
however
as the game matured we decided that we
needed more control over the size and
the scale and performance of the
database
so
when we're looking at different
providers we saw that spanner
has consistent indexing
that allows us to do more complex
database schemas with these primary and
secondary keys
datastore was also
non-relational with atomic and
durable transactions
so
we needed a relational database with
full consistency and made the choice to
go to spanner which gave us these global
asset transactions
well it's great to see that you started
off with a single backend that worked at
the time and then quickly evolved that
architecture
to include the components
that made more sense as the game grew
now let's say i'm a player and i'm
playing the game right now i open my app
to catch a pokemon what is happening
behind the scenes how does the request
flow work when the user catches a
pokemon we receive that request through
the google cloud load balancer
all the static media is also stored on
google cloud storage buckets and is
downloaded to the uh to the phone when
you first start the app we also have
caching enabled at the load balancer so
it's all cached and served through
google cloud cdn
so when the poke when the player catches
the the pokemon
the gclb sensor request to our gke
cluster
and we have a front-end service that
sits behind a nginx reverse proxy
the request goes from the user's phone
to the reverse proxy to to one of these
player front-end services
we also have this thing called a spatial
query back-end it's a cache by location
so
that is where we store
the information that determines where a
pokemon is shown on the map what gyms
and pokestops are around you what time
zone you're in or any other feature that
is location based
the way i like to think about it is the
front end manages the player and their
interaction with the game while the
spatial query backend handles the map
the front end retrieves the information
from the squibby to send back to the
user
so the spatial back-end it sounds like
it's a custom database of sorts that
presents the map and the pokemons
now what happens when i hunt the pokemon
down and catch it when you catch a
pokemon it sends the request to the
front end to the spanner database where
your player entity is stored and it's
stored there
for catching pokemon that actually
doesn't go to the spatial query backend
um if you were instead if you were
battling in a gym or adding lures to the
pokestop that information is stored on
the spatial query backend and then the
data gets eventually consistent at which
point that
the player the players receive the
update and then it's used for
all the other players that are in your
vicinity
the front end that point will retrieve
the information from the spatial query
backend and send it back to the user
we also store this information using
protobuf and write this data into
additionally we also write this data
into bigtable
um which we also use for logging and
tracking purposes with
with very strict retention policies
um we also use pub sub to send the kind
of a message to a pub sub topic which is
then used for our anal analytics
pipeline
so how do you ensure that when two
people who are in the same geographic
regions see the same pokemon data and
keep that relatively in sync especially
during the events so it's actually
pretty interesting everything in our
servers are deterministic
so even if players are on different
machines
they're sent to be the different
front-end services
um they all are if they're in the same
physical location all the inputs would
be the same and the same pokemon will
get returned to both users there's a lot
of caching involved and as well as
precise timing especially when the the
settings are changed and they need to be
in sync across all the servers so
it's very tricky but it was very
important for us
that all the players feel like they're
part of this one shared world speaking
of analytics we talked a little bit
about pubs when you're sending these
messages into pub sub for analytics now
there's massive amount of data that must
be generated during the game how does
data analytics pipeline work and what
are your what are you analyzing yeah
you're correct um there's like 10 to 20
gigabytes of data that gets generated
on a daily basis and stores all of it in
bigquery
this this game data is of interest to
our data science team
they use this for for marketing purposes
for for verification for
like for example
we might want to say that
this player or player's caught
x millions amount of pokemon during
during our saturday community day events
so it's important that we have that
information in an easily accessible
manner
we also use dataflow as our data
processing engine to run batch jobs to
process the player logs that are sitting
in big big table one example of that is
using uh cheat detection we might look
through logs and notice that a player
used to be in japan and then a minute
later they were in australia so we
wanted to check for that and make sure
that we're responding to improper
improper player signals
on the other side of things we also use
google dataflow to set up pokestops and
gyms and habitat information all over
the world
we take in information from various
sources like openstreetmap the us
geological survey
and wayfarer which is our crowdsourced
website for players to submit
uh points of interest in their
neighborhood and combine all that
information to build a living map of the
world now as the events grow like you
mentioned in some of these events the
traffic grows to millions of users per
second you also said 10 to 20 gb of data
is generated how does the system scale
when it comes to data pipeline yeah so
what with this increase of transactions
there is increase of load throughout the
system with a lot of our data pipelines
for for things like bigquery a lot of
that just works uh google cloud will
will handle the increase in traffic
without any any intervention some of the
other things we'll just scale
preemptively and make sure we we work
with google to
to
make sure that we can support that
traffic with that much traffic obviously
health of the system is critical as well
how do you monitor the health of the
system during these massive events
so we use multiple
monitoring systems including prometheus
grafana and google cloud monitoring on a
personal level i actually prefer to
google cloud monitoring because it's
very simple to use uh for me it's very
easy to set up graphs to set up alerts
and
um not have to get really into the
nitty-gritty gritty details of some of
these other implementations everything
just is very easy to use in google cloud
and google cloud monitoring well it was
awesome to hear the in the entire
implementation and the architecture
details i am very sure you have
something in mind or you're cooking up
something to evolve this architecture
right now um what are some of the
expansions and improvements you're
looking to do
uh in the future on the google cloud
side of things we are looking into
things such as agonias and google game
servers and using that to to see how we
can make our game even better we wish
you and the niantic team best of luck
for these enhancements and this has
obviously been super insightful for us
james thanks for joining me today and
sharing your architecture with us yeah
thanks for having me this was fun well
we just took a behind-the-scenes tour
into pokemon go's architecture how they
use gke and spanner for scaling to those
high peaks and how their data science
team works with bigquery data flow and
pub sub for the data analytics want to
learn more check out the links below
like and subscribe while i catch some
more pokemons